Here's everything I ate today while not being able to cook
since we're out in Connecticut right now.
We started our day off at Arden's.
I need multiple beverages,
so I had a matcha latte, orange juice,
hot chocolate, and some tea.
I ordered this mushroom toast with over easy eggs.
They weren't quite perfect,
but it still worked. Before I could even start eating my food,
lucky was already done with his breakfast tacos
and got his second round of food.
This toast was so good. I've always loved mushrooms,
so this toast was so good.
I'm still thinking about it.
I kind of wanna go back to have it.
But after we had breakfast,
we headed over to the stables to see some horses.
Rumbles been begging me, and Paige was so nice to let us.
After we were done with that,
I really wanted some good apples,
so we went to pick some and filled a little bag with them.
Nothing beats a fresh apple.
I also picked up some plums since my parents are coming into town.
And then we headed over to get some lunch.
Pizza seems to be a staple around here,
so we went to this pizza place that looked really good,
and we got one of their salads,
which was just a simple salad,
nothing groundbreaking.
We also got some pepperoni pizza with some peppers and onion on it.
And I got a Margarita pizza as well.
Obviously
had to top our Slices with some Parmesan cheese and chili flakes.
And this was actually really,
really good.
I ended up having half of the pepperoni and half of the Margarita one,
and we headed over to the mall.
Lucky made me try this cinnamon roll,
which was vile. I don't know why these are so popular.
And then for dinner, I just was craving some meat.
So we found this steakhouse,
got a mocktail, lucky got this spinach artichoke dip that I tried,
and then I just got a classic steak and fries.
I couldn't finish it all, so lucky ended up finishing my plate.